are already but what was kind of the
decision between having your comment and
what was what was it like having her
under under the basket there maybe you
know it's crazy
um
my daughter called me the other day
um when she was getting out of school
and she was just you know she just said
dad can I kind of come to the Toronto
game I remember going to all the Toronto
games when she was a kid and I almost
said no because she in school back home
um she kept asking she was just adamant
about coming to support and I just said
uh you convinced one day at school and
you know come to a game and I'm glad I
did um I ordered some money for sure
uh no she gotta go back to school nine